Teamwork leads to greater efficiency.
Whatever be the job, a complete set of people
in co-ordination can make it possible.
But a team is usually considered incomplete
without a leader.
A leader is the one who not only guides, but
even regulates or controls the working of
other team members!
The same analogy can be used to study the
cellular organelles.
The various organelles are like the in charge
of specific functions.
And can you guess who acts like the leader here?
It’s the NUCLEUS !
You heard me right!
The nucleus is the controlling unit for every organelle.
Located right at the center of the cell,
it governs the functions of the other organelles.
But how does it regulate the activities
of other organelles?
Let’s try finding it out in this video!
The reason why nucleus is given the status
of the major cell organelle is because it
contains the GENETIC material of the organism.
Now what could this genetic material be?
If we zoom in this nucleus,
we find these tangled thread like structures.
Any idea what these structures are?
These are called the chromatin fibres !
Are they important to us in any way ?
Well, they are the most importan component
of the nucleus and even the complete cell !
Because these chromatin fibers
enclose the genetic material within them!
When the cell has to divide,
these long threads coil themselves to form a
sophisticated and compact structure called
the chromosome !
We have come across this term often!
It look somewhat like this!
These chromosomes are made up of
smaller important segments.
These functional units are called genes.
“Genes” form the basis of heredity in all organisms!
That means the similarities and variations
that organisms have with their parents!
For example , what do friends and family say
when they see a baby?
“She looks exactly like her mother”
or “She’s so much like her father”.
That is because the new born baby gets her genes
from her parents!
Now let us zoom in a bit more!
Any idea what these functional segments named genes
are made up of ?
Genes are made up of molecules of DNA.
You heard me right!
Deoxyribonucleic acid , abbreviated as DNA,
forms the genes!
So now if we go in the reverse manner,
then we have DNA molecules forming
functional segments called genes.
Many such genes come together to form the
chromosomes.
However, the compact chromosomal structure exists
only when the cell is about to divide.
So usually, when the cell is in the resting
or active phase apart from cell division,
the chromosomes exists as tangles threads
called chromatin!
In other words, chromosomes and chromatin
are the same thing!
The genetic material is locked in the form
of these chromatin threads
present in the nucleus!
Now this was about why the nucleus
is called the major organelle.
But any idea
how the system of regulation works?
Well, that happens with the help of proteins!
The genes present in the nucleus
code for specific proteins.
These proteins perform various functions
that we find in the cell.
So functions right from passing information,
communication or even building structures,
all these are carried out by the specific proteins.
That is how the nucleus helps in regulating the
various functions of the other cell organelles.
Unlike the other organelles,
even the nucleus has its own membrane that separates
the inner contents from the rest of the cytoplasm.
The membrane however has pores to allow entry
and exit of substances across it.
Also, the nucleus has its own nucleoplasm that is
slightly different from the rest of the cytoplasm.
Now that we have learned about the
ruling organelle in the cell,
let us deviate towards the other working organelles
as well!
Let’s try learning about the remaining organelles
in our upcoming videos!